the Joe Rogan experience I was reading
this thing about Yale and that Yale put
tampons in the men's room because they
said not everyone who men straights is a
woman and I'm like yes they are I
thought maybe they worked for diarrhea
no yes everyone who menstruates
is a woman scientifically we're getting
woman right now lucky yeah it is it is a
weird thing that's happening oh anyone
whatever they want it's just a weird
yeah I will too
I have no problem I want I would I would
love to make you happy as long as it
doesn't it's so wacky well Chappelle
said that thing on his special rece ed
to what degree do I have to partake in
your self esteem right that's a good way
of looking at it yeah yeah I mean it's
but it's not just that it's it's an
enforcement there's like an
authoritarian enforcement of certain
language in certain ways of
communicating with people yeah you know
there is a goddam hilarious thing the
Tim Poole posted up of a communist
meeting where this woman is calling
everyone comrades and this guy is like
could everyone please stop moving
because could you guys please stop
moving because I have severe a DD and
all this moving is really distracting me
and woman goes all right Thank You
comrade duly noted and then the guy goes
please can you stop using gendered
language when you say that in my very
it's very offensive and like it is woke
God this is what I was saying before
about how it's like if you're expecting
the world to accommodate to you like
you're safe spaces inside yourself you
fool it's inside you you don't have
control of the outside world this is
people trying to control the language of
everyone around them and then saying
it's unsafe if they don't follow your
new vocabulary that's an unfair thing do
you find it and he said this can't be
real it's like two days ago he put it me
a Sam Harris reminded me of it as we
were [ __ ] howling laughing about it
it's it's just John's it's like a parody
it's like the onion is not ridiculous
enough and like these people are more
ridiculous than the most ridiculous
parody like you can't even mock it but
do you think that it is them trying to
see what they can get away with yes
they're little how far can I go their
play make-believe they're there I'm a
chicken you know as someone said this to
me I can remember it was but that all of
the the words the key words that people
are using now like triggered save space
their autistic terms their terms that
people use with autistic let's chose yes
play this if we want to defeat
capitalism we are going to need a party
that will or cease working people to
fight for the demands that we want and
to win socialism thank you so much guys
first of all James Jackson Sacramento he
him to a minimum I'm one of the people
who's very very prone to sensory
overload a lot of whispering and chatter
going on it's making it very difficult
for me to focus just I know it's we're
all fresh and ready to go but can we
please just keep the chatter to a
minimum it's affecting my ability to
focus thank you point of personal
privilege yes please do not use gendered
language took to address everyone okay
monster where is he right in the lower
right hand corner with the the halter
top what of that's the one that jumped
up
that's the he him she he's wearing that
he's wearing that red so when he gets
his period do not use gendered language
this is this is where we're at we're at
where in nonsense land and people are
acting like this is normal you're bunch
of babies
what do you give a [ __ ] if someone says
yeah who cares what was said about these
girls say girls I could be there say
girls I don't care this is your your
crazy
please do not use gendered like what how
does that change anything and by the way
where you can if you can't deal with a
bunch of people moving around and
distract making noises and [ __ ] just
stop yeah get the [ __ ] out of there yes
force everybody else to deal with you're
[ __ ] weak mind go home
there's
watch this on YouTube eat a steak do
some squats mistake eat some elk get
your [ __ ] life and [ __ ] baby it's a
week alright go [ __ ] a god Bigfoot will
write a Bigfoot [ __ ] book and make
millions
what is this seminar about about being
an [ __ ] comedy just it's just so it's
like playing on this thing to where it's
like I want people to feel good I was a
special ed teacher I've done all these
things the special ed kids wouldn't have
been talking like this asking for all
these things and well this is what they
with these kids are calling socialism
right like this is what I mean everyone
has to be like super super sensitive and
aware of every single [ __ ] thing they
do and every single [ __ ] thing that
everybody around them does just to
comply and it pleased you have victim to
because it's impossible for that to
happen so no one's ever gonna comply to
everything you say there's always gonna
be one person even if they don't even if
they want to maybe they were listening
to something else and they didn't know
that that's what they were supposed to
do or whatever so then there's always
gonna be you're always gonna be a victim
of something someone's always said the
wrong thing they've always done the
wrong thing and all of your worth is
from something outside of yourself and
you now don't have to deal with your own
but also just it ramps up what used to
be acceptable year ago now is
unacceptable a year from now it'll be
something else after a while you won't
even be able to say colored you're gonna
have to say the c-word right you have to
say you can't say people of color which
is a yes a is that people color that's
what that is a weird one well yeah like
the n-c-double-a or n-double-a-cp
brother National Association for the
Advancement of Colored People which is
bananas like ya can't say that you can't
even say that anymore it's like so dumb
it's such a weird thing and also people
I feel like if people stopped having
attachment towards you could stop having
them mean anything like they wouldn't
hurt you well the Jews talked about that
in the 60s it was one of his bits in the
60s would he would call people by a
bunch of ethnic slurs and then say you
know the problem with not saying these
words is that if you say these words
enough time they lose all their meaning
and it's not gonna hurt ya feelings I'm
paraphrasing but this is the opposite
and you know what they did to him
nothing they turned him into a woman and
Miss Mazal
[Applause]